to the agenda please
item one on the agenda election chairman
of the council
please can i have a nomination for the
position of chairman of the council
councilor arthi
thank you chairman um i'd like to
propose catherine grandin
we all experienced catherine's
chairmanship in the first two years of
this term
and i'm sure you'll agree she was a
credit to the council
unfortunately the covert lock downs
meant she missed out on so many of the
civic and the ceremonial duties which
was such an important part of the role
for her
and which she carried out with such
confidence and a degree of elegance too
catherine grandin is an excellent
representative for this council and it's
my pleasure to propose her
can i have a second to please
council ward
yeah uh thank you
i'd love to second catherine for this
role um as you all know she's had a
period of illness but she's uh fighting
back and is raring to go and is up for
the challenge and i'm sure she'll be uh
just as much of a credit second time
around as she was before unfortunately
obviously uh she's not able to be here
with us today because she is enjoying a
very nice garden party at buckingham
palace so um i
would love to propose catherine as uh
the second captain rather as chair of
the council
thank you
there any further nominations counselor
barrack
yes i'd like to nominate
a very confident counselor whose attempt
may i have a second to please
counselor
norman
uh yes no i would like to
um i would like to second councillor uh
suez i think should be a great getting
to the council and do great in the role
thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you
sorry counselor
could i just have the monitoring officer
to give her opinion as to whether
um a nominee for council for the
chairman of the council uh can be put
forward if they are not present thank
you
thank you chairman happy to answer that
it is something that we actually checked
ahead of the meeting
and it is possible to be nominated as
chairman without being physically
present at the meeting thank you
councillor mayberry
can i just point out that i'm um
apparently i'm being um
advertised as my colleague councillor
fraser so i don't know if
one of the officers would like to swap
us over please thank you very much
is that in our constitution
um thank you it's not something that's
stated in our constitution it's just
recognized custom and practice so it's
something across the board um there is
no legal requirement or constitutional
requirement in in any constitution
um in any model constitution that the
person who's being nominated has to be
physically present for their nomination
it may be worth chairman for me to just
describe what will happen if councillor
grandin is elected
the incumbent chairman will stay in in
the seat until the vice chairman is
elected and then the vice chairman will
take over the rest of the meeting
yes councillor it does apply unless a
council has made some other
constitutional arrangement that requires
the presence
thank you thank you
emily
now
council of halt
miranda wishes
can we now go to the electronic vote
please
so councillors we're going to take the
first nomination which is for councillor
grandin if the council votes and it's
over um 50 of the council which we have
30 members present so if we get to 16 we
will take that boat as appointed if it's
a draw then we will then go
to the next boat and then if it's still
a draw we will use the chairman's
casting vote so just so that you know
the process so all those in favor for
council brandon can you now put your
vote in please
uh
thank you
thank you members uh there were 24
and 10 against so that
that is carried
thank you
sorry
yeah i'm sorry
so i declare councillor catherine
grandin duly elected
not 24 24
f.o.r
just
one of those things
tonight
what
thank you members
before i
uh move to item two on the agenda
i would like to take the opportunity to
say a few words
firstly i would like to give my sincere
thanks to the officers who have
supported me through the last difficult
12 months
they have
they have been there for me whatever the
situation
and though all through all the
challenges
although at the beginning of my year
there were still restrictions in place
that prevented many events taking place
i have still attended some wonderful
occasions
and met some wonderful people
many of them i have known for many years
either through my cricketing or my times
as mayor of sudbury
and i leave my year as chairman with
some wonderful memories
i would like to thank those who have
very kindly supported my charity the
kernel center
again
fundraising has been limited but i
managed to be to do a sponsored walk
with jan
and also hold a very successful and
enjoyable charity dinner at henderson
mall
with many
thanks to your generosity and that of
businesses in baber i have raised
3450 pounds for my charity
thank you all
this
this i know will be greatly received by
colonels
i wish councillor grandin all the very
best in this year as chairman
thank you and i would like to move on to
item two on the agenda thank you
may i have nominations for vice chairman
councillor arthur
thank you chairman
um well ex-chairman actually thank you
thank you councillor i was born in the
chair
um i'd like to propose derek davis
derek has respect and maybe even
admiration across the district he is a
man with a sense of understanding and
fair play to all
i'm sure he will provide excellent
support to catherine and proudly
represent the whole of baby district
council
thank you thank you
may i have a second please
counselor
um i would like to second the nomination
of my colleague here derek davis as vice
chair of this council gives me a great
pleasure to do so thank you thank you
are there any other nominations
then i will ask the manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair if councillors would
like to place their vote it is now
showing in blue
not green it's not green it will be
it will be sorry it's a bit slow
um
[Music]
um chair so that is um 18 votes four
nine against and three abstentions
i declare councillor davis duly elected
and i'd now invite the incoming chairman
to sign declaration of acceptance of
office
that takes some time
oh
um
thank you
this one
yeah thank you very much everybody um
i just now have to make the official
declaration here
having been elected to the office of
vice chairman of the council
hereby declare that i take that office
upon myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
i undertake to be guided by the suffolk
local code of conduct in the performance
of my functions in that office
um i'd like to say first of all thank
you all for the nomination
um
especially councilorathi and councillor
gould who i've known for quite a while
now living on the peninsula together
there
um i'd also like to thank all my other
councillors for supporting me
i am truly
humbled and honored to be elected as the
vice chairman
i'd also like to give my thanks and pay
tribute to the outgoing chair councillor
adrian osborne
he has given the role a good innings in
qriket terms as you would expect and
will be a hard act to follow
he has been an excellent chair and a
credit to baber
he has had to chair the council through
the most challenging and unprecedented
times and has demonstrated real
professionalism and commitment
throughout his term of office
thank you adrian
[Applause]
we will now proceed to apologies for
absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
grandin and councillor hinton
so now we have
decorations of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
for any of the items coming up
okay now to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 22nd of march 2022
this is for accuracy only
are there any issues with the accuracy
can i have a proposal then please to
accept the minutes
council award
and the second or please
council rosberg
okay
i think the uh the officer is going to
take this on a show of hands so all
those in favor
now we have the you go to paper bc
2222 for noting council award do you
have anything to report as leader of the
council
i do vice chairman
just uh just a few things everyone um
firstly i just want to draw your
attention to the leveling up and
regeneration bill which was announced in
the queen's speech earlier this month
the bill is a long one
it has 11 parts and 338 pages
i just want to highlight a few of the
proposals in the planning and
infrastructure levy
parts it specifies a number of
amendments to existing legislation
regarding planning and local plans for
example local plans will be simplified
by providing national policies in
general areas so there's no need for
local policies in those areas
there'll be mandatory design codes
and plan making will be streamlined by
having gateway checks on plans before
examination uh replacing the local
development scheme with a simpler local
planned timetable process and also the
five-year land supply requirements for
the first five years of a plan will be
removed
all these amendments are designed to
ensure that it takes no longer than 30
months to produce a plan
there'll also be a new infrastructure
levy replacing sill which will be
locally set and collected and it'll be
charged on the sale value of a property
and with the threshold to provide a
build cost allowance to negate viability
debates
there will be a new right to acquire an
affordable percentage
the neighborhood share will be retained
and the infrastructure delivery strategy
will specify use of the levy with
priorities and there will be a duty to
engage with providers now i can provide
more details summary for anyone who
would like it
you will see in last week's media
release that we will be holding a new
public exhibition showcasing plans and
proposals for sudbury next month
this will update residents on progress
on several projects since our last
exhibition in january 2020
while we focus on providing support for
our communities and businesses during
the covered lockdowns we also made
progress on our plans particularly the
regeneration of the hamilton road
quarter which is a very complex and
difficult scheme
visitors to the exhibition will be able
to get an update on plans for the future
of market hill
the development of the hamilton road
quarter and also the new cafe at
bellevue park
also developments on the virtual high
street and new innovation lab in boron
gate which will provide a resource for
start-up and small businesses
there'll also be a range of other
initiatives and projects on show
including gamesworth's house saint
peter's church and the solar carport in
the station road car park
and finally visitors will also see the
new initiatives from the british project
and we'll be able to find out about the
work of the sudbury culture group which
promotes the town's attractions and
heritage i'm sure it'll be a great
success and generate a lot of comment
and feedback
our next curiosity event takes place in
sudbury on the 1st of june
curiosity is the skills and education
initiative for young people aged 13 to
24 which is led by babe and suffolk
councils and which aims to inform young
people about fantastic and varied range
of jobs available in suffolk and how to
access them
the sudbury event
is about the marketing industry and has
been hosted by branding and marketing
agency macmillan group in meadowlane who
are really committed to the event the
feedback from past events has been
excellent and those attending have found
them worthwhile and meaningful
more information can be found on the
website so please encourage any young
people you know to attend and mention it
to schools and youth groups if you get a
chance
and finally
yesterday evening the chief executive
and i were kindly invited to the sudbury
annual time meeting to
tell everyone about what baby has been
up to in the past year
now i'm used to getting quite a warm
welcome when i go to my parishes and my
ward indeed only last week to fairly
full church in haim after i delivered my
annual report i got a round of applause
so it was with some surprise and and
gratitude that following an hour of um
giving our reports and taking questions
we also received a round of applause
from uh the the attendees at the uh
annual town meeting it was a very
worthwhile event um
there were some very good questions and
everyone was really appreciative of the
fact that we
trying our best to engage more with the
town and improve what has admittedly at
times been a fractious relationship
i had a good chat with the clerk and
also the new mayor ellen murphy
and she was very appreciative of the
fact that we put in the effort to do
that and they were very interested in
what we had to say so
all in all a very good evening for us
both
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you council award okay we'll now
move on to
paper seven the designation of
committees and joint committees
this is to appoint the following
committees and joint committees overview
and scrutiny committee planning
committee licensing and regulatory
committee joint order and standards
committee joint appointment committee
could i have a proposal to appoint all
the committees listed on the agenda
and i see that on planning um the
conservative group of ten members have
three seats
the independent group sorry to interrupt
i'm sorry so we're on the we're on the
wrong path with that one so you because
you're on paper right and we're on paper
seven well i did say that i was
eight right you
i'll wait then thank you
okay so we'll go back as a proposal i
believe who who
counsel carpenter thank you very much
proposed and a second
council award
so this is for paper seven
item seven designation of committees and
joint committees
okay
so
we're going to take this electronically
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors could place their
vote
okay
uh
chair that is 30 votes for
thank you very much
so now we'll go to um paper eight
and i understand councillor beer wants
to ask questions
thank you mr chairman i'll start again
um
on the planning allocation of placements
um there's 11 seats
there's three for for the conservative
group out of 10 members
there's three for the independent group
out of 10 members
green labour party
and independent
uh conservative group i don't think they
can be conservative but anyway
they have two seats
when you look at the conservative
allocation of three that is one third of
the members when you look at the
independent conservative group of four
members that is 50
now
as you saw earlier i'm not that good on
maths but
uh when i went to school 50 percent is
half
for four people and yet ten members get
three seats
that cannot be right it cannot be
transparent
and that really is not acceptable
yeah
i know we're going to be told how this
has all worked out in a moment but
i'm afraid as far as i'm concerned in
the public that i represent this is a
disservice it is not correct it's not
right thank you obviously i'll refer
that to the monitoring officer to give
you clarification on that
thank you vice chairman so the rules
around the political proportionality of
committees
relate to the overall proportionality of
each individual committee and being
representative of the proportions that
each political group holds on the
council as a whole
it is not relative to how many seats you
have on a committee compared to how many
people you've got in your group
so it's about that percentage
representation across the whole council
and then we have to
map that across each committee and as a
whole number as well which is why
mathematically you don't always get neat
rounding because there has to be some
give and take to get that overall
balance so i take on board the point
that you're making councillor beer but
it's not something that we can take into
account with the proportionality
however if you'd like to move an
amendment to the proposed numbers
if that's proposed and seconded and
voted on
then the council could consider that as
as a change to the table paper
so if we can then do
sorry
well
in fairness the
the monitoring officer has given you an
explanation on that and and you know
we'll accept that and i think it's
possibly something you take out of
meeting because now we need to move to
the designation on that and if you want
to vote against it you can
we need to have it
i don't agree with her assessment but i
but i understand that that is what's
been said so i accept that yeah but i
don't agree with it that's fine that's
fine i need to take a proposal from the
sector first and then obviously we can
have the data and then i can do an
amendment right thank you
councilman yes thank you chair i just
wondered if it would help the situation
for councillor beer to draw his
attention to appendix a which contains
the breakdown of all those um
allocations of committee placements
because
we need to keep to the um
system first of all first of all we'll
take a proposal
for this um
proposal councillor busby
yes i have please i just wanted
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah i've
got a question actually about the
relevantly independent group
can we just confirm that that is a group
of ten
because
clearly by the name if you're an
independent
you stand by yourself
so
have they formally formed a group or are
there any actual individual independents
that are not part of that group be an
independent group is an obviously more
issue
yeah but historically um that was
exactly how it was many years ago but
a councillor in this chamber actually
asked that similar questions some years
ago and it became a formal thing but i'm
more than happy for councillor arthi to
give further clarification
um
and we are a group for political
purposes we are not a political group
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um well yes i'd
like to increase the membership of the
um
ten conservative members
which is the conservative party
um
from three to four seats
and remove one conservative
member from joint order and standards so
from two to go down to one
thank you very much surely that's quite
possible and that would look better to
the public thank you
dawson
do you accept that amendment or do we
need to go to a vote
uh
i don't accept that amendment no they've
currently got 11 seats for a group of 10
so i don't think they should be
complaining
yeah
okay so we start with council award you
have a question um
yeah
you can't do that without having an
impact on um
that
you've now increased the number on
planning to 12 and reduce the number on
order standards to
asking for they're asking to
increase the conservative number and
reduce other uh he hasn't said that he's
just talked about um
all he's mentioned is to increase the
conservative membership of planning to
four and reduce the conservative
membership on audit standards to one it
doesn't make any reference to any other
uh groups did i get it wrong
my apologies
mr independent leader
um
conservative independent no not as far
as we're concerned
um the
the um two
uh independent conservative groups of
four they they should be reduced to one
so that would make the balance that's
part of your amendment yes
thank you very much
so council halt
yeah councillor busby made
or just announced a number of 11
conservative seats he failed to announce
that the independents have 11 seats and
the green party six
and the independent conservatives four
and the liberals three
for clarity i think that's important
that we make sure that everyone knows
how many seats there are i'm sure
there's more seats than there are thank
you thank you i'm sure the council is
very grateful for your uh summing up
i just asked the monetary officer to
clarify everything so we're all very
clear where we are
thank you so just to confirm the uh
intention of the amendment
the planning committee would remain at
11 places the conservative group would
have four of those seats and the
independent conservative group would
have one of those seats
and the joint audit and standards
committee would remain at five places
the conservative group would have one of
those places and the independent
conservatives could have two of those
places
mr chairman i think it is just important
that i highlight to the council if you
were minded to agree that amendment
the independent conservative group have
three out of their four members on the
cabinet and therefore would not be able
to take up two seats on the joint border
and standards committee
that's right so we need to i think if
anybody's got any more debate if not
we'll go to the vote yeah okay thank you
thank you thanks councilman mccrory
and then i'll go
and i apologize to emily here because i
may be misreading the table in appendix
a but it shows at the moment
no independent conservative on joint
audits and standards
so their proposal is not to go from uh
zero to two is it it's to go from zero
to one there's a swap here i think
there's only one position actually being
proposed not
not being able to available on on
scrutiny or an audited committee is very
well made indeed it also causes
considerable problems where any
substitution ever to be required and it
risks leaving a committee uh being
incorrect and i would never want to see
that
thank you council hull did you have a
question
it was just the monitoring officer
mentioned the um
cabinet members can't sit on that
committee are there any other committees
that um
we have that cabinet members shouldn't
or would rather we prefer them not to
sit on which includes planning
thank you chair the two um committee
actually three committees um or two
committees one panel so the two
committees that cabinet members are
prevented from sitting on are our
scrutiny committees so overview and
scrutiny and joint order and standards
committee
and cabinet members are also prevented
from being part of the joint standards
board
thank you
is anybody else like to um
no so we'll move to the uh to the vote
electronic vote again so thank you chair
we're voting on the amendment as tabled
if you could cast your votes please
um
10 votes for
and 20 against so that amendment is lost
okay thank you so that fails and then
we'll go to the substantive motive um
motion
chair so if you can now go to the vote
to agree recommendations 2.1 and 2.2 as
detailed in the report that is now
showing in blue
[Applause]
mr chairman point of order on the
previous vote
normally when we have the voting the
four boxes in the top
and then it's again so on the previous
vote the four boxes at the bottom yeah
that didn't follow the convention
we'll get our technical experts have a
look
is
you were still in the vote yeah
councillor dawson are you able to vote
electronically
uh
can i take it manually then
council dawson sorry just for
clarification what was your vote
has gone through okay thank you
thank you chair that is 20 votes four
and ten against so that is carried
i will go to the uh oh sorry councillor
busby
yes chet thanks can i just say that uh
decisions on planning committee
shouldn't be politically driven anyway
so it shouldn't make any difference what
the party structure is
right so uh we now go to the election of
chairs and vice chairs of committees
so
in accordance with the council's
constitution
article 6
6.2.1 the leader shall take up the
chairmanship
of the cabinet
now we need to elect a chair and vice
chair for the following committees
overview and scrutiny committee
planning committee licensing and the
regulatory committee
and then we need to elect co-chairs for
the following joint committees joint
order and standards committee joint
appointments committee
so first of all could i have a
nomination for the chair of overview and
scrutiny committee
councillor board
yeah i would like to propose councillor
hinton for this role um
he
councillor hinton uh reads every paper
from beginning to end he's forensic in
his analysis of the papers um he has has
often been critical of many of the
papers that have come forward and i
think
with that background he would be a very
good independent and effective chair of
the overview of scrutiny committees so
i'd like to propose castle hinton thank
you
okay and do i have a seconder
councillor casarathi
do you want to say something and if you
want to
very briefly then um
yeah similarly to
um john here i think john hinton has the
kind of intellect and probing nature
that is so valuable
in um scrutiny
i'd go so far as to say he's probably
actually the perfect fit i'm happy to
support his nomination
thank you are there any other
nominations actually there's one other
thing i wanted to say castle hinton of
course as everyone will remember was the
very first independent conservative that
this council had
and he was soon joined by others but
anyway councillor barrett i believe you
had your hand up
please uh the vice chair is going to
take that attitude i think he needs to
roll it in because that's the wrong
comment we're not going to have any of
that
thank you please sit down please sit
down
please sit down that you've taken
tonight
um i'd like to propose sean dawson
to be chair of overview and scrutiny she
has the necessary skill to share this
very important and very valuable
committee
so um
thank you very much about your support
sean
do we have a second place
[Laughter]
i was i was waiting for the uh for the
lights to go out um yes thank you um i
would like to um second councillor
dawson for the for this um for this
position
um i think from her experience um
over the years through other activities
and also for the fact that um
she's very diligent on a lot of items
that she would be very good in the
position so thank you very much
so chair taking the first nomination
counselor hinton can i have your votes
please
um
chair that is um 20 votes for
councillor hinton and 10 against so that
is carried
so councillor hinton is duly appointed
chair of overview and scrutiny committee
may i have nominations for vice chair of
overview and scrutiny committee please
could i have a
any nominations
for vice chair
oh councilman mccrory just beat you to
it
i'll defer to council award
everyone's been
after you george okay okay well i was
going to um propose uh councillor adrian
osborne um
uh he's sat on the committee for a long
while and he is
he knows the work of the committee and i
think he'd be
an excellent vice chair
okay thank you and is there a second
before
councillor osborne councillor mccraw
and i can testify that he's an excellent
vice chair
okay so we'll now take the vote on that
any other nominations
no
okay we'll take the vote
thank you chair that vote is now open if
councillors would like to cast their
vote
it's sorry it's been a bit slow it's is
there
council holiday for are you having
issues
cancer plumber you have any issues with
voting
can i take it manually then please
and cancer adrian osborne
chair that is um
24 nine against and one abstention
so that is carried
so council osborne's duly appointed
okay so now can i have nominations for
chair of the planning committee please
council award
yeah i'd like to propose counselor plum
as chair of planning he's been in the
post for a year now um he's learnt the
role and he's become a very effective
chair of planning and now is not the
time to make any further change to this
we've got another year to go before the
elections next year and i think council
plan
would be ideal to retain the role and
continue for another year
thank you is there a second of the
council of plum councillorathi
thank you i haven't really got anything
to add to that thank you i support that
okay so any other nominations councillor
barrett um
his experience is uh sadly lacking in
the planning department at the moment
uh seen we seem to have a large amount
of
appeals coming through is there any
relation with the current chairman's
position
he's um i think we've seen a decline in
the standard of the chairing and i'd
like to see that counselor beer is
reinstated so we have a proper planning
committee again
is there a seconder for that
council in norman
oh yeah i'd like to second councillor
beer for chair of planning for the short
time that i was on planning uh
councillor beer was a great chairman
made some great decisions and yeah i
would like to see
it thank you
thank you
any other nominations
so i'll ask the corporate manager
governance and civil office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair so we're taking the
nomination for councillor plum
as the first nomination can you please
place your vote
um
um
thank you chair that is 20 votes for and
10 votes against so that is carried
so congratulations councillor plum
you're julia appointed as chair of the
planning committee
now may i have nominations for the vice
chair of planning committee
councillor plum
thank you acting chair um i'd like to
propose lee jameson um over the last
three years i've seen him come on to the
planning committee and grow into
a very very experienced member of the
team and i think it's about time now
that he took on a bit more
responsibility so i'm not making advice
to you thank you do i have a second
offer
counselor
yeah i think so
sorry chairman i think as we move
towards more sustainable building um and
biodiversity becomes so much more
important in all developments um i think
it will be a real asset to have
councillor jameson as vice chairman of
committee
you don't have any other nominations
so i'll ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote will now be
turning blue as we speak hopefully
and that is now open thank you
uh
uh
cancer dawson um
have you managed to vote or is this
um chair that's 21 votes four and nine
against
congratulations councilman
jameson
so may i have nominations for the chair
of licensing and regulatory committee
please
counselor arthi
thank you chairman yes i'd like to
propose lee parker
lee is a man of honesty and integrity
with good judgment and a keen sense of
fair play i think he'll be excellent in
this role and i'm delighted to propose
councillor lee parker thank you could i
have a second to please
thanks councillor lindsey
okay are there any further nominations
councillor beer
thank you mr chairman um well yes i'd
like to propose um margaret maybe
she's been the chairman for a little
while and
very efficient uh certainly reads all
her papers
and conducts the meeting very well i
think we're
really blessed for having somebody who's
prepared to put in commitment to tell
you i'm not saying once at moment that
you wouldn't believe um but i certainly
think that um cancer maybe should be
allowed to continue
but i think i know the figures thank you
and can we have a second of
the council halt i'd like to second
councilman raybury uh i think she's done
an excellent job in her term in office
and through the taxi policy especially i
thought she led
particularly well and looked after the
interests of our taxi businesses in
sudbury and hadley and across the whole
district
and i think that lead alone would uh be
enough i think for most members to see
that she's an excellent
chair
any other nominations
thank you chair um that vote to for the
first nomination to elect council parker
is now in blue if you could place your
votes please
uh
yeah
thank you chair that is 18 votes four
and 12 against so that is carried i
declare councillor parker is duly
appointed as the chair of the licensing
and regulatory committee
could i now have a nomination for the
vice chair of license and regulatory
committee please
counselor
thank you vice chair well behind every
good man has to be a good woman so i'd
like to propose councillor cottondale
she's been in this role she's very
experienced she'll be a brilliant backup
to councillor parker and
pleasure to recommend her thank you and
the second to please
council malvisi
thank you very
much yes i'm like a second counselor
part of them she's done an excellent job
i've worked with her on
various papers that
yes
some
snacks
very
any other nominations
so if i ask the governance officer to
conduct focus
thank you chair that vote is now going
to turn blue if you could cost your
votes please
um
is
councillor haran are you able to place
your vote would you like to place it
manually
getting there quickly my computer went
to sleep
but
yep
sorry coming through now okay thank you
chair that's 22 votes four six against
and two abstentions thank you
thank you
okay that's carried then councillor
carmel davis vice chair on that one
so now gonna have nominations for the
co-chair of joint order and standards
committee please
any nominations
council carpenter
thank you chair
um i'd like to nominate ben haram for
this role
he has experience now as a joint chair
the audit and standards committee is a
very important one
he has a good grasp of the agenda and
when it comes to standards um his
integrity is beyond question i'm very
happy to nominate him
thank you do i have a second for
councillor councillor busby
i'm happy to second that um yes he's
very effective
he's been in the role some time now plus
he's good at sums
do i have any other nominations
and no other nominations okay so
i'll ask the governor's office to get
out the vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for councillors to cost their vote
uh
cancer malfeezy do you have a problem or
is it okay thank you
council maybe are you having issues as
well
okay thank you
thank you chair that's 22 votes four
five against and three abstentions so
that is carried thank you so councillor
is due
is julie appointed co-chair of joint
order and standards committee
so can i now have nominations for the
co-chair of joint appointments committee
please
a nomination
councilman
oh it's an interesting position the
joint appointments committee because i
note that obviously the leader of the
council is no longer
sitting on the joint appointments
committee which seems a little bit
is that your nomination no
counter-intuitive i'm asking this to
emily yield as the monitoring officer
but i assume it's the three largest
groups is that correct
in that case i'd like to nominate
councillor asi to be the joint chair of
the joint appointments committee and i
seek a secondary
council award
uh yes i'll second this um it's not a
committee that meets very often
but um council arthur will be fine as a
vice chair
any other nominations
no i'll ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote please
thank you chair that should now be
turning
blue if you could place your votes
please
there we go she'll be there
um
yes
can i take your vote please
you're voting
it's for councillor arthur to be
appointed as the co-chair of joint
committees
chair that is um 24 and 10
against so
councillor arthur is julia appointed
co-chair of joint appointments committee
okay so uh
we now go to paper 10 bc 22 4
appointments to outside bodies for 20 21
22. is that right
yeah so 22 23.
first of all i just want to say that
there's a slight amendment on your paper
and uh allison owen is now um down as an
observer for the citizens of the vice
uh bureau as well as adrian osborne
okay
so and that's as you see appendix a in
the table papers
and i'd like to uh invite the leader to
introduce this paper and move to the
recommendation in the report
thank you chairman um yes so i'd like to
propose that the
list of appointments to outside bodies
that are detailed in appendix a
is accepted by council apprentices
provided in your agenda supplement pack
we do have to review these from time to
time not just in terms of the membership
but also
in terms of whether the the bodies
themselves are the appropriate ones to
appoint to
the criteria are listed in
paragraph 3.2 of the report but before
we
go any further there are three things i
just want to draw your attention to in
appendix a
firstly
and and this has been something that has
has continued first several years i
believe we still don't have anyone
nominated for these internal drainage
board
the haven gateway partnership
we're no longer represented on that so
that needs to be removed from from the
list
and finally
councillor
mclaren um it's no longer able to sit on
the suff violence suffolk violence and
abuse partnership so we do need somebody
to to sit on that that's probably the
more important one to to get resolved
this evening
so
as part of the recommendation i would
like a nomination to replace council
mclaren on that body okay so i'll go for
a second the first do you have a
seconder
councillor busby yeah uh cats yeah i'm
coaching sorry cancer mc mayberry i'm
just i'm taking council mccoy first
because i've said i'd i've already said
i would do that so councilman crawl
it's only a matter of our technical
thing that the last um annual council
the suffolk internal drainage board did
come up
i was appointed to it i can
confirm it has not yet met in the course
of the last year but it does fit in with
the role i carry on the on the
suffolk scrutiny
flood management scrutiny subcommittee
so at that point that appointment was
made might be willing to carry on as i
said if yet to meet in my experience
that would be suffolk drainage at least
dealt with
councillor maybe
thank you vice chair and i've got um two
actually three comments to make um first
of all because you are
appointing observers to submarine
district citizens advice bureau i
declare that i am a director
of said organisation secondly you're
saying that there are going to be two
observers but under the
numbers there's only one
so i don't quite understand that
um and the third comment is about the
east drainage board or whatever one
calls it because it's got such a long
name that is actually
used within planning um a lot so i think
that's quite an important um position
to be on are you volunteering yourself
i could do it no problems
certainly
okay so i understand that there's two
positions on that board and allison of
course council macquarie is one and if
you're happy to be the second that that
would be ideal
well it looks like i've got myself a job
thank you very much
chairman do you need a proposal for
those two we've got proposals i think
council award proposed we need a second
okay right and you don't need a second
or anything we need a second down i'll
second it if you want thank you
councillor mayberry and councillor
mccraw
this is for the whole
whole whole yeah yeah i thought those
nominations needed
no they're added they'll be added in
yeah and and the same as um as as the
the person or the
what is missing council award what is it
you need
the suffolk violence and abuse
partnership
yeah anybody like to volunteer for that
while we're wrapping it all up
counselor maybe um i think
mr vice chairman that i have a lot of
experience for this
and i t and i keep in
any reason for that look smartly
um i also keep in close contact with um
the main officer terry um cudby so i'd
be delighted to do that as well thank
you okay is that okay council award
absolutely yeah definitely okay so we
filled all the places so now we just
need to oh sorry council macro
it's just the point of order of the
haven gateway partnership is still
listed i thought we were uh leaving the
haven gateway
that i did mention that's fine i
apologize
chair if i can just clarify as well
about the citizens advice um there was
only one position as a this afternoon
but we have spoken to the organization
and they are willing to have two
observers hence why we've got two
so
um nominations
ten positions okay so if we can go to
the vote now
yeah i'm more than happy to have a show
of hands so just for simplicity so can
we have
a show of hands for the appointment so
the outside body is detailed in appendix
a
that's that's carried by a long way
great stuff
okay so
so now we go to the appointments of the
shared revenue partnership
so do we have any nominations
for councillors for the shared revenue
partnership joint committee
that's awesome
so again should we do a show of hands oh
sorry cancer osborne and then i'll come
to council award
thank you very much
um
okay
so this
and a seconder for that
councillor mclaren
thank you vice chair yes i'm very happy
to second um
those nominations because we've got two
very experienced counsellors
and uh their cabinet members which of
course is an initial criteria thank you
okay the nomination is really table
thank you councillor maybe
yes thank you um
mr vice chairman and this is um this
question is to the monitoring officer um
since there is going to be or there will
is now a shadow cabinet
surely the shadow cabinet is eligible to
be on that committee
thank you
happy to answer that question vice
chairman
because this committee exercises
executive functions
only members of the cabinet
can be part of that committee
i'm going to come back on that one
to the monitoring office there i'm
actually going to argue that point as
you know i would
um as i have always argued the point to
be the barrister on licensing and
regulatory
um i don't actually think that's correct
um and i think the constitution needs to
be looked at or governance at least
because surely if if it is a formal
appointed shadow cabinet
then the shadow cabinet has the same
rights as the
other cabinet
get the monitoring officer to clarify
for you
thank you vice chairman um a shadow
cabinet is not recognised by our
constitution there is no formal role for
it
and there is no formal links to
appointments so it remains that for a
committee that exercises executive
functions
only councillors with executive powers
i.e members of the cabinet
are able to sit on that committee
um if it's something that you would like
to put forward to the constitution
working group then that's something they
could consider
but do you want to take this outside
council maybe because i don't think
we're going to achieve anything here now
are we
oh okay
okay
all right so that's good so in that case
i'll ask the corporate manager
governance and civil office to conduct
the electronic vote
so chair that um paper that vote is now
turning blue and that is with the
additional um sub as councillor arthur
as amended thank you
do you want to do it by show of hands
then this one
or is it going
going it is going right thank you so
cancer are you for or against
cancer barracks
just a bit slow
um chair i'm really sorry but the whole
system seems to be hanging at the moment
so can i just take it by show of hands
please so all of those in favor of the
appointments as tabled can you put your
hands up please
and those against
thank you
so that is character
okay that that's carried
so well
yeah we'll go to
please please
okay now we'll ask for nominations have
been tabled um for appointments to the
suffolk joint standards board so could i
have a proposal for that please
counselor arthi
thank you chairman i think i'm doing
this at the right time um i'd like to
propose lee parker
i think i said enough
glowing um
about mr parker earlier on so i won't
say any more okay
this is for the vacancy that's on there
so could we have a second to please
counselor
any other nominations for the vacancy
okay so i think we'll go to a show of
hands if that's okay because of the
system and for save time
so can we have a show of hands in favor
of the suffolk joint standards board
including councillor parker
so there we go
please come on
appointments to the joint gypsy and
travel and steering group um the council
is asked to appoint four councillors to
the joint gypsy and travelling steering
group the nominations have been tabled
please gonna have a proposal
councillor osborne
any other nominations
cancer maybe did you want to speak or
i was actually going to um do the
proposing but there we go
okay
it's going to halt
just looking at the nominees it doesn't
give a great um geographical spread
across the district does it something i
know that members do like to see
and um i wondered if that is really
appropriate when we're looking at this
gypsy traveler's site locations etc
perhaps if i just try and offer some
reassurance um obviously when members
are appointed to these kind of bodies
they are there to represent the whole
district not just their board interests
thank you
so once again we'll do a show of hands
for this one please for the uh the four
councillors to the joint gypsy and
travel austere steering group all those
in favor
that's okay
it's unanimous
so council is asked to appoint
councillors for the following working
groups as tabled
community governance review working
group
constitution working group
member learning and development working
group local plan working group
so could i have a proposal
please for these for the
that have been tabled councillor
mayberry thank you um mr vice chairman
um i'm actually going to make a comment
um particularly for the member learning
and development working group and some
people are going to be upset with this
comment but others hopefully will not be
um i am really surprised when we have a
wealth of
uh retired and serving teachers and
lecturers
that they are not used for their
experience and expertise for
all of this
um i do acknowledge that councillor um
carpendale is on there and has the
experience but i would have thought the
better placed people would be those who
have been
in education and i'm not putting myself
forward for it even though i am
quite capable of doing it and i have the
expertise but there are others
thank you
thank you we are voting for the names
that have been tabled so so first of all
could i have a proposal please
counselor arthi and a seconder
councilman crawl
okay again we'll do it by a show of
hands all those in favor of appointing
the councillors to the fight to the
working groups as outlined
so that's all of those thank you for
your patience and for the votes and
we'll now go to the
questions from the public
and i will refer you to the questions in
the table papers and first of all i'd
like to invite mr allen ferguson to ask
his question
i'm sure there's a switch here only on
the mic but thank you for turning it on
my question to council award refers to
the introduction
of revised car parking charges in baba
cabinet minutes from last year
show that as leader of baba district
council and the conservative group
you originally supported a cabinet
decision
to introduce increased car parking
charges in the district
subsequently you changed your position
on this matter
when with the support of additional
conservative cabinet members
it was agreed that increased car parking
charges
would not be introduced
in the foreseeable future
as you have now resigned from the
conservative group and crossed the floor
to become an independent member of baby
district council
have you changed your most recent
position on car parking
namely the baby district council will
not introduce additional car parking
charges
in the remaining period of this current
administration
okay i'd like to ask council aboard to
respond to that question
thank you jim
thank you for your question mr ferguson
regarding the vexed matter of car
parking charges
firstly i would like to say that i'm not
an independent councillor like you were
and to my council of beer several others
currently in this chamber were sitting
over there i am an independent
conservative councillor
i do acknowledge that this is the most
controversial and divisive decision that
baber has ever made and so i'd first
briefly like to provide a reminder of
the original cabinet decision in
february 2021
currently we have three hours free
parking with a limit of three hours in
short state car parks and charges for
stays longer than this in long stay car
parks
the changes we approved will reduce this
free period to one hour with very modest
charges between one pound and two pounds
stays between one and three hours
depending on location
the average dwell time in our town car
parks is 64 minutes and so a large
number of users would be unaffected by
this change
as you are aware the cabinet decision
had cross-party support as indeed did
the 2021-22 budget which included the
financial impact based on the proposed
implementation start date july 2021 as a
result of the then ongoing effects of
the covert pandemic the conservative
group changed its mind and the start
date was postponed in the autumn of last
year
irrespective of my personal view the
cabinet decision from february 2021
still stands
the implementation date has not been
decided yet but will be announced well
in advance of new charges being
introduced
thank you chairman thank you do you have
a supplementary mr ferguson
uh
council's declared intention
to start developing the old council
accommodation
at cork's lane later this year
can you tell me how baber intends to
replace the
about 100 car parking places
across the river that we've been lost
as the current car parks are now at full
capacity
uh even without the planned growth
and there does not appear to be any
alternative site available
in hadley
thank you council ferguson it's really a
supplement fuel first sorry not
calcified mr ferguson
this is not really a supplementary to
your original question however um what i
will say that uh the car parking
capacity that you are referring to the
spaces you're referring to are not
official parking spaces um when i've
passed by and i do
several times a week
those those car parking areas are not
very
heavily utilized and in any event we
have carried out surveys on the official
car parks in hadley
that show that there is plenty of spare
capacity on pretty much every day of the
week
thank you
thank you
thank you for your time mr ferguson
okay
okay
now we go to questions by councillors in
accordance with the council procedure
rule 13
i refer you to the questions in the
table papers
before i invite counsellors to speak i
just make the point that any
supplementary question does have to be
regarding the the the initial original
question so please bear that in mind
if asked if asking us a supplementary
question okay now i'd like to invite
councillor dawson to ask her a question
yeah
thank you
last year's full council on the 18th of
november
i requested clarification on the
financial position of corks lane
on the fourth is cabinet member for
assets and investments he provided a
breakdown summary of the full annual
running costs being half a million
against an original budget of 342
and future calculated development cost
13 million against a budget of 12.9
you advise development works would also
commence in spring 2022.
as we are now past budget and that date
um
please could you give a definitive date
when this project
is expected to commence
and
spring
we've got another month in spring to go
but thank you for your question relating
to the former hq property of course lane
hadley
a report is tables for the cabinet in
june to consider the next steps
in relation to this development which
subject to the cabinet's decision could
mean that uh works could start
on site in august
thank you councillor busby council
councillor dawson do you have a related
supplementary
um you know i think as ward councils has
been very damaging so
what bothers me is the approach
agreed by the cabinet
in december 18 would enable the scheme
to be brought forward quickly
using a construction group
this would overcome the
necessity for a lengthy procurement and
in december you said this was um you
know coming forward in december and here
we are in maine we haven't heard
anything
the written management describes the
description cannot be so let's cancel
the dawson question
is there a question there yes
listen the business manager describes
the description cannot be delivered or
on or within budget within time scale
and any delay could it lead to increased
costs
this was considered unlikely however i
believe the timing is significantly
delayed and materials and everything we
all know have increased from 18 to 35
so therefore i think the figures you
gave me a
3.77 million capital funding
is not going to be sufficient
would you not agree with that
apologies i got the number wrong it
isn't 500 pounds a year
for the first one it's 50 000 pounds but
for your uh the follow-up question um no
the the
i mean the 3.77 million is the borrowing
ceiling that we're referring to
the costs are in the region of about 13
million
depending upon the phasing of the work
depends on how much
borrowing that you need at any one
particular point in time
if you do the work quickly you need a
higher
borrowing requirement
but you can be more certain about the
overall price because contractors will
hold their prices if we spread
the work over a longer period we can
work with a lower debt requirement but
we can't guarantee the prices so
yeah and contractors have come out and
pulled out councillor dawson can you let
councillor busby answer the question
please
have you have you finished cancel the
busby yes sir
thank you very much
okay we'd now like to move on to uh the
next question and again i'd remind you
it's a question and the supplementary
has to be a question and no speeches
please
counsel a beer
i'll be brief and direct to the point
thank you counselor afi
could you please advise me and the
taxpayers of baby district council if
the extra 100 000 pounds allocated in
the budget for the junk local plan is
good value for our residents
as we've seen unable to deliver a
satisfactory scheme
thank you
thank you
the answer to your question is yes
our planning teams have done a fantastic
job during a difficult couple of years
um and the cost of the joint local plan
is good value for our residents
who i believe expect some some certainty
for the future of labour and consistency
in our decision making
as a former chairman of planning
committee and a member of the
cross-party working group that helped to
deliver that help to develop the plan
for submission i would have thought you
would be aware
that we are now in the hands of the
planning inspector for examination and
modifications
which will be subject to public
consultation later this year
would you like to ask a supplementary
question counselor beer thank you mr
chairman yes i'm very aware counselor
arthur
how much extra money will the joint
local plan cost
since the inspector
gave instructions to officers to review
and resubmit the plan
i don't know that amount yet um and i
don't suppose anybody else does either
we know it's going to cost more money
because we've got a lot more work to do
i can try and get you a more accurate
figure probably slightly later in the
year
it sounds like an open checkbook i'm
sorry thank you
yeah please yeah just for clarification
i think you've got to remember that we
have to deliver a plan and i would be
very surprised if i don't know if you're
involved in this shadow cabinet are you
but i would be very surprised that if
you were involved in that and you had a
role from a planning point of view but
you didn't see that
shadow doesn't mean being out of the
light and not seeing the light
okay thank you all very much um that
that's excellent
and i'd just like to now wrap up the
meeting and let people know the date of
the next meeting is tuesday june the
21st 2022 at 5 30 p.m
and now i declare the meeting closed
thank you all for your patience
you